a hulking dude won the ncaa d1 women's
swimming and diving championship over
the weekend and now
everyone is pretending to care about
women's sports and they are doing that
because it's the most socially
acceptable way to criticize
transgenderism so now people get to say
i'm not anti-trans and people should
totally be able to do whatever they want
but this is wrong because this is not
fair to girls
true it is not fair to girls
but that is not the point
the problem with transgenderism is not
that it makes it complicated to
engage in college swim meets the problem
with transgenderism is that it's a false
account of human nature that encourages
delusion psychosis and self-mutilation
that's the problem
people are making this issue way more
complicated than it actually is either
the transgender belief that men can
secretly be women and vice versa is
correct
or it isn't
obviously
it isn't
so then why are we restructuring our law
and our politics and our culture
according to a premise that every single
sensible person in the entire world
knows is absurd
there's an answer it's not just a
hypothetical question i actually think i
know the answer the answer has to do
with our national obsession with
openness and permissiveness it has to do
with our confusing liberty
with licentiousness licentiousness just
the
fulfillment of any appetite that you've
got this is a confusion that our
founding fathers like many other wise
men throughout history warned us would
completely sink our republic we want to
be open to everything we want to
tolerate everything we want to be really
nice we don't want to be close-minded
that's the worst thing you can be
illiberal that's the worst thing you can
possibly be and so a lot of people want
to split the baby on transgenderism
by encouraging it in some circumstances
but not in others and the way that they
do this is by using the language of
individualism they'll say
listen here if a man wants to wear a
dress and call himself sally well by
golly that's his right that's none of my
business so i have no right to infringe
on that but
he can't infringe on my rights or the
rights of those girls who are swimming
this strategy has never worked and it
will never work because the man's
alleged right to pretend to be a woman
necessarily infringes on our right in
society to treat men as men and women as
women
we live in a society these
rights quote unquote rights affect real
rights that we've all got the man's
quote unquote right to pretend to be a
woman infringes on women's right to have
their own bathrooms infringes on our
right to call people by their correct
pronouns
infringes on the girl swimmer's right to
compete against women in the ncaa
championship
there is only one way
to stop transgenderism
that is to oppose it
entirely the whole thing
for young people for old people
on this continent on another the whole
thing there is no
natural
or constitutional
or civil right to fantasy
and there is nothing compassionate about
encouraging disturbed people to indulge
their destructive delusions
yes it's unfair that transgender
ideology permitted william leah thomas
to take a trophy away from a young woman
at a swimming competition
but it's unfair because it's unjust and
it's unjust because it's based on a lie
if you recognize that something is wrong
with this picture then stop pussyfooting
around the issue the only way to stop
this madness is to stop tolerating the
ideology of transgenderism in all times
in all places full stop i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from king of
mustache who says if i had a nickel for
every time a woman thought she could end
the ukrainian war with slam poetry i'd
have two nickels which isn't a lot but
it's weird that it happened twice that's
true
it's not a lot you're not saying it's
happening everywhere but it is weird
that you've got the kooky actress lady
who comes and says hey i know how to
stop putin hey putin
how about you quit luton that country of
ukraine it's insane you know and she
just goes on and on on the video and
then it's not just some wacko in
california
in the entertainment industry it's also
a wacko from california in the political
industry named nancy pelosi who does the
same thing reading from bono i don't
think it's going to work i'm not saying
that you can't turn russia's troops back
and send them home
i don't think you're going to do it with
very very sloppy poetry that is in fact
the death of art that's probably not
going to do it that's not you can rest
easy knowing that that is never going to
work when you really want to rest easy
though i recommend you check out helix
right now go to
helixsleep.com for the greatest sleep of
your life here like sleep has a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you you are unique you are special okay
why would you sleep on someone else's
mattress why would you want to sleep on
my mattress first of all i'm a married
man second of all we're different people
so go head on over to helix they've got
soft medium and firm mattresses
they've got mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains even a helix
plus size mattress for plus size
sleepers if you're looking for a
mattress take that quiz order the
mattress that you're matched to comes
right to your door shipped for free you
never need to go to that mattress store
again they've got a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights risk
free they will even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will love
it so it's super easy flexible payment
plans right now get 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com knowles
that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200 off and two
free pillows
a picture
tells a thousand words
and that picture of william thomas who
goes by the name leah
standing on the podium with his
championship prize
and then you've got number two and
number three there was another photo
where it's just the actual girls sort of
crowding around taking a photo of one
two three
william thomas completely on the side it
tells you everything you need to know
there was another photo of thomas
wearing his
women's swimming suit
and uh
lots of things were clear from that
photo
okay lot lots of philosophical things
anatomical things it was just
preposterous and will thomas at the
women's swimming competition gave an
interview afterward to say what this
meant to him
i can't tell you how free i feel now
that i've started identifying as a woman
now that i can compete as female i'm
ready to smash the other girls
and is it correct you just started
identifying as female two weeks ago i'm
not here to talk about my transition i'm
here to kick some ass let me tell you
something dingleberry david perry i'm
gonna roll up the other women here and
i'm gonna smoke them
i am the strongest woman this state has
ever seen
sorry that was a clip from south park
which predicted this exact thing that
would happen and back then it was a joke
and it was it was satire and now it's
become reality because satire is
completely dead here is the clip of
actual will thomas at the women's
swimming competition
you've undoubtedly been under the
spotlight over the past few months how
have you been dealing with that and
reasoning with everything
i try to ignore it as much as i can
i try to focus on my swimming
uh what i need to do to get ready for my
races
and just try to block out everything
else
i just try to block out everything else
like reality that's what he's blocking
out what's amazing about the clip is and
you're lucky that you didn't have to see
the lower half
it
it's obvious that he's a man in in some
cases with transgenderism there are
enough perverts in the scientific
community that they'll poke and prod and
shoot you full of hormones and chop
things off and and give you cosmetic
surgery that it's not always totally 100
clear
if a person is a man or a woman
because of all the crazy interventions
that people have now but in this case
it's just totally clear he's a dude he's
a hulking dude with super broad
shoulders with all of his anatomical
features that he has had since the day
he was born with a relatively deep voice
just talking like a guy the only thing
that he sort of did
was grow his hair out a little bit and
then put it in a swimming cap anyway
there is no
question here that he's a guy and so
they say well what do you make of the
criticism that you're cheating these
girls out of their trophies
what do you make of the criticism that
this is wrong and unfair and unjust and
he says i just block it out and that's
all we're doing and this is not just a
will thomas problem this is not just a
girl's collegiate swimming problem this
is a society problem is that
when
deluded people in this society
come across a fact that they don't like
they not only want to block it out but
increasingly they can block it out
because we're so isolated now the the
structures of community that used to
keep us somewhat tethered to reality the
family the civil society the government
for that matter they've broken those
tethers and so now you can go you can
sit on your phone scroll all day long go
into ever more fantastical delusional
communities and be affirmed in your
crazy incorrect beliefs then you can go
to your various affinity groups
and gain political power and then force
this stuff to
try to manipulate reality so you go and
you say look there's a whole group of us
who we're convinced now that men are
actually women so we're going to
completely change women's sports and the
craziest part is because our society
doesn't have anything to stand on
anymore because we've rejected
theology and philosophy and even the
existence of objective truth this the
coaches and the administrators and the
schools go along with this crap and the
government goes along with it too and
now guarantees it what do you do when
you hear criticism well i just block it
out of course you block it out and i'm
not necessarily criticizing will thomas
i actually have this i i don't think
it's likely but i do have this strange
thought i thought
what if
this guy's just a performance artist
what if this guy is doing a super
deep
performance where he's showing the
absurdity of transgenderism because he's
a hulking dude he beats all the women in
the swimming matches he tunes out the
criticism he exposes society for being
completely incoherent on this issue and
then at the end of his college career he
gets out he's like guys what are you
what were you thinking i'm obviously a
man why would you give me the women's
trophy this is wrong look at you look at
what's become of you i don't think
that's likely but it certainly could be
for for everything that we know about
this
let's say that he is sincere let's say
that he really does think that he's a
woman that should be a cause for our
compassion and empathy and pity and we
should try to convince him of reality
instead of telling a disturbed
individual
that all of his delusions are real and
encouraging him down a path that is
destructive not only for himself
not only for those girls who didn't get
their trophy because he was beating them
because he's a dude but for all of
society as well
you know what's really destructive to
your time and money
driving to the brick and mortar auto
parts store that's why you got to go to
rockauto.com
right now go to rockauto.com do it right
now because if there is even a part that
you think you might need
in the future for your car for your
truck you're going to want to order it
now inflation is going through the
freaking roof do not put this off do not
wait certainly don't go to the brick and
mortar auto parts store where you're
going to be paying 30 50 sometimes 100
more for the same parts rockauto.com is
super simple even i can navigate the
website there's no gimmicks you don't
need to wait until tuesday at three in
the morning to log in and get x percent
off no it's always reliably low prices
it's the same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers this is a family
business that has been serving auto
parts customers online for over 20 years
and they're great supporters of this
show which is one of not even the number
one reason that i love them but it is a
reason that i love them it takes a lot
of courage to come on and support good
good old-fashioned patriotic shows so
show them some love go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck write knowles
k-w-l-e-s in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
this whole show is going to be taken
offline today right
there's no question this is good it's
going to be taken offline because this
it's called hateful conduct
it's it's violating twitter's and
youtube's and facebook's rules
if you state basic truths now
it at the very least we're told we have
to couch these basic truths so you've
got to you can't call a man who thinks
he's a woman a man you've got to say
well he's a biological man
as though there were some other kind of
man right the way i know this is the
attorney general of texas ken paxton
just got in a ton of trouble because he
came out and he was tweeting about the
assistant secretary of health who's a
man who thinks that he's a woman and he
tweeted out and he said rachel levine is
a man
and he was flagged for hateful conduct
there and the thing i loved about it is
that
paxton didn't put any qualifier there
he's a he's a biological man the
biological man thing drives me
completely insane
because
people i know why people do it one they
do it so that they can get around the
social media sensors and two they do it
to be specific because now we don't have
a common definition of the meaning of
the word man and of woman and so they'll
they're trying to be really specific and
they say well but speaking biologically
he's a man
but what they don't realize is that when
you use the phrase biological male or
biological female
you're not opposing the ideology of
transgenderism you're you're granting
the whole premise you're granting the
whole premise of transgenderism is that
you can be biologically one thing but
really another thing or spiritually
another thing or psychologically another
thing i'm biologically male but
psychologically female no you can't
that's not possible
you're just a dude or you're a chick and
that's that
and yes in extraordinarily rare cases
there's some ambiguity with people's
genitals but it's extremely rare and
that's not the phenomenon we're talking
about here we're a hulking dude with
broad soldiers and all of his parts in
order just pretends to be the opposite
of what he is okay
so i i really encourage people follow
ken paxton's lead the only problem is
you probably will
face consequences for that
because the people who are disconnected
from reality and who are encouraging
other people to be disconnected from
reality
have all the political power and it's
not the
reason we all focus on this
transgenderism issue is because one it
cuts to the heart of human nature sex is
right there at the very heart of human
nature genesis the first chapters of
genesis what do we talk about the
difference between men and women the the
first
lines of
so many creation myths stories that we
tell ourselves about human nature
including scientific stories including
the theory of evolution or the theories
of evolution it begins
so early on you hear this difference
between men and women it's a much more
important distinction in human nature
than race or nationality or geography
even it's sex really right there that's
one reason we focus on it the other
reason is because it's just it's so
preposterous it's so obvious it's right
there before our very eyes how
disconnected from reality the ruling
classes but it's not only on this issue
there was a tweet
that bloomberg
media company put out there that i
thought perfectly exemplified the
disconnect between the ruling class the
liberal establishment and all of the
rest of us bloomberg news is there
anything that screams liberal
establishment more than bloomberg news i
don't think so and they
they gave some advice on how to deal
with inflation
they said
inflation stings most if you earn less
than 300 000 a year
here's how to deal for okay i'm going to
pause it right there
do you know how few people earn 300 000
a year i love this bloomberg coming out
and saying you know look if you happen
to be one of those unfortunate indigen
probably homeless people who doesn't
even earn 300 000 a year
you're probably gonna have some trouble
with inflation
okay and here is how you deal with it
and i kid you not this is this is their
advice
take the bus
don't buy in bulk
try lentils instead of meat
number four nobody said this would be
fun
try eat eat lentils pores
that is what the liberal establishment
says on how to deal with inflation not
hey we're going to stop printing more
money not hey we're not going to shut
down the economy for two years over a
stupid cough that we didn't need to shut
down the economy for
not
hey we're going to
have an energy policy that encourages
domestic production so you don't need to
spend a gazillion dollars at the pump
which is actually driving a lot of the
inflation no not any of that
there eat lentils pores and by pours we
mean people making less than three
hundred thousand dollars a year namely
everybody statistically everybody in
america makes less than three hundred
thousand dollars a year the vast vast
majority of people make less than three
hundred thousand dollars a year just eat
lunch and oh take the bus and that's
better anyway because that'll stop
global warming
us no we're not going to take the bus
but we're helping too because we're
going to go buy teslas buy a tesla oh
you can't because you're a poor person
who makes less than 300 000 a year well
eat dirt
well eat potato soup because
no no one said this would be fun i mean
it's fun for us it doesn't sting at all
we're good rich people but you figure it
out just eat some slop stop eating meat
stop being so selfish that'll help the
environment too us no we're not going to
stop eating meat but you you should
this is
a ruling class
that
obviously holds the majority of the
population in absolute contempt we've
known this for years they call us
deplorable they call us irredeemable
they call us all sorts of nasty things
right bitter clinging bible thumping you
know how the list goes on
but they're also just so
freaking removed from reality
i do not want to ascribe to malice that
which is equally explained by ignorance
or stupidity
these people
i don't think they can hear themselves
or just eat lentils what's the you eat
lentils how about you go eat lentils how
about you go take the bus mike bloomberg
no i don't think you're going to do that
are you nobody said this would be fun
you know what's going to be a lot of fun
you know it's going to be a lot of fun i
i still think that people in this
country have some political power and
i'll give you my evidence exhibit a
prime evidence number one in just one
second
the people still have some political
power are we a properly functioning
democracy or republic i don't think so
have we crept into elements of oligarchy
is there a ton of corruption in our
government do we have faith in our
elections anymore do we have faith in
our institutions no not anywhere near
the amount of faith we had in them
just a few decades ago but i do think
the people still have some power in this
country and i do think that we can win
back some political power and we can put
these freaking jerks in their place eat
lentils how about you i'm gonna pass a
law it's the make the
make the liberal establishment eat
lentils act of 2023. uh you give me your
meat i'm gonna end up a communist by the
end of this these people are so
provocative in their disdain for the
american people
well well come on monkey just go eat
some lentils
frankly i want to eat the rich after i
after i hear these people say this stuff
it's so out it's so audacious
can't
can't have a country if you hate all of
your countrymen a very small percentage
of americans right now are really
showing us their contempt but there is
some good news
and this is the this is the evidence i
think that the the american people still
have some power
dr fauci
might retire
when you are in politics there is a
tension there is an eternal tension
almost always you have to choose between
one of two things
when you're a conservative in politics
do you want to be right
or do you want to win
because politics generally just gets
worse and worse and worse from the
perspective of modernity if you're a
conservative
and so if you if you give
the accurate prediction of what is
likely to happen
you're probably going to be right but
you're going to lose politically because
conservatives have lost almost without
exception for
half a century now more than half a
century okay and so if you
if you're right
you lose
because the people who are right
generally the ones predicting that we're
going to lose
this
is one example where
i think we get to be both
the news that fauci might retire came as
the third episode of my three-part
docu-series fouchy unmasked was released
i'm not saying i did this okay i'm not
saying it was all me or even somewhat me
but what i am saying is
when i floated the michael knowles
public health protection pledge that
gained a lot of steam got a lot of
candidates around the country to sign on
actually was introduced in the house of
representatives
almost verbatim to investigate dr fauci
and take out his salary
within days of that pledge coming out dr
fauci disappeared from all the news
shows he basically went into witness
protection okay he vanished into thin
air and then
within days of my docu-series faucion
mask being released and getting a lot of
traction dr fauci says he might retire
i'm not saying it was me okay
but i'm not saying it wasn't me all
right i was all you know there are
sometimes there are coincidences all
nature is but art unknown to the all
chance direction which thou canst not
see what i can tell you is all three
episodes of fouchy unmasked have dropped
they're all available on the website
check out this sneak peek
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you where a mask
keeps social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony fountain don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
the series is streaming now it's
available exclusively at the daily wire
if you're not a member head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
we'll be right back with a lot more
i've got good news and i've got bad news
the good news is dr fauci says he might
retire
are you thinking about scaling back your
responsibilities here at some point well
i have said that i would stay in what
i'm doing
until we get out of the pandemic phase
and i think we might be there already uh
if we can stay in this then we're at a
point where i feel that we've done
well by this but you know i i don't have
any plans right now to go anywhere but
you never know i was going to say is
retirement like on is retirement or
stepping back into a consultant role any
like that are you considering those
options brad i certainly am because i've
got to do it sometime
i can't i can't stay at this job forever
unless my staff is going to find me
slumped over my desk one day i'd rather
not do that
he says i'm i might retire i've said
look i can't stay here forever
i mean i've been here through 17 million
presidents i've been here you know since
i was around st petersburg when i felt
there was time for a change i've been
around a long time but no i can't stay
here forever
and so
look we might be at the end of the
pandemic
what was that it's almost it's like a
little if statement right
if the pandemic was over
then i would
retire
but but then the question is
is the pandemic over he says maybe it is
but then he says
maybe it isn't
dr fauci he gets our hopes up he says no
i might retire tries to get that
pressure off tries to get that public
health protection pledge off tries to
get that rand paul senate amendment to
get rid of dr fauci and abolish his
position tries to take the heat off of
that tries to
avoid the heat when the faucio mass docu
series tries to get away
from the clear public turn against him
but he leaves himself that out
he says well
listen here maybe i don't know that we
can totally say that we're done
the director general of the world health
organization is is sounding the alarm
though saying that the pandemic's not
over do you think it was too soon to
move to the new metrics that allow so
many americans to to not have to wear
masks jake
it's not too soon
if you observe the caveat that's
associated with that
and the caveat is we need to be flexible
and if in fact we do see a turnaround
and a resurgence we have to be able to
pivot and go back to any degree of
mitigation that is commensurate with
what the situation is so we can't just
say we're done now we're going to move
on we've got to be able to be flexible
because we're dealing with a dynamic
situation
no we can't just totally say that we had
done ever no we and this wasn't just a
flub this wasn't just a gaff where he
finally he reemerges he goes on the
sunday shows just like i told you told
you he would everyone said oh he's gone
forever they're gonna keep him away no i
said he's he's held on he's got you
might re-emerge
don't he might go see his shadow and
we'll get six more years of covid he
goes on the sunday shows too he goes on
abc he says well you know
we got rid of the mask mandates we got
rid of the vaccine minute but but maybe
we gotta pivot
if we do see
a significant surge particularly one
that might result in increased
hospitalizations we have to be prepared
to pivot and perhaps reinstitute some of
those restrictions reinstitute all of
those masks and vaccines and reinstitute
good old dr fauci on every television
channel in america that's what we're
going to do i told you this would have
you know i hate to say i told you so and
i told you this would happen the way i
knew this would happen
is that when the democrats threw up the
white flag or seemed to throw up the
white flag on kovid
they kept the power
they never got rid of it and so i warned
i said this is probably a fake out
they're saying kovid's over because
covid
lockdown measures and the masks and the
vaccine mandates and everything they're
killing the democrats in the polls
and this is an election year and the
democrats are on the ballot in november
and so they're trying to make it seem
like it's over
but it's a fake out
because if it were really over
they would get rid of the
national emergency authorization about
kovid
the senate tried to do that there were
even democrats in the senate who wanted
to get rid of the national
emergency authorization for covid joe
biden vowed he said i will
not sign that
i will
veto that
the airline mask mandate that should
have been gone right if if kovid's over
if the emergency is over we already know
from
even members of the liberal
establishment that the masks are not
quite as effective as we were all told
they were in the beginning lyanna when
the medical analyst on cnn said it's
nothing more than a facial decoration
and yet when the time came to get rid of
the airline mass mandate what happened
the airlines extended just another month
just another
just two more two weeks to slow the
spread then it'll probably be over right
it didn't get rid of any of this stuff
the only reason they had to get rid of
some of the federal mandates on the
masks is because we at the daily wire
beat them in the supreme court so they
lost on that one that's why some
corporations are getting rid of it too
but they held on to the power because
they're gonna bring it back
and they're they're just debating do we
wait until after the election to bring
it back
or will it help us to bring it back
before the election and get everybody
freaked out everyone had their attention
on ukraine for a while so ukraine was
the big issue and that distracted
everyone and so they lessened the focus
on covet but now the ukraine issue seems
to be dying down a little bit i mean the
war might not be dying down but as a
matter of uh concerning the public it's
not it's not quite as captivating
anymore so okay now we're going to go
back to covid and they seem to be
bringing it back again the only way
that we are going to end
the covid tyranny the dictatorship of
little dr fauci is if we do it ourselves
using political power
it's not just about well follow the
science and maybe we'll meet halfway and
this and that and maybe in this area we
don't need masks but here we do it's
kind of like the transgenderism issue
you just got to throw the whole thing
out you got to throw it all right out
the window
either
we're going to have a country run by dr
fauci
or dr fauci needs to shut up and go away
either men can secretly be women
or they can't
and we're not gonna we can't split the
baby on this that's never going to work
these people
who have been
running our lives and shutting down the
country and causing record inflation
and driving our country into the dirt
for the past two years
largely in the liberal establishment but
some republicans have gone along with it
too they don't know anything jen saki
the white house press secretary was just
asked at a press briefing about
why
you still have all these restrictions on
schools why schools we know that the
kids
face very very little risk from covid
compared to everybody else why why are
why the hold up with the schools and she
says with a completely straight face she
says oh we don't know that kovid affects
older people
more strongly than younger people
if the president 79 years old president
of the united states were to get kovitz
might be more serious than
uh you know somebody in their 20s well
we don't know that um but we also know
that covid impacts people of all ages
and
a range of but we take what we do here
jen is not not exactly as you said so i
wouldn't agree with your description
there i would say we do take extra
precautions
we do know that
as much as we know anything about this
virus and epidemiology and social
science
we know that young healthy people do a
lot better in the face of covid than do
frail old people
we just know that and it's it's not even
close it's not like it's a margin call
we're talking about many many multiples
orders of magnitude more risk
for older people
than for younger people and that has
always been true the entire time and
nothing about the science has changed
and nothing about the science is
ambiguous
and they're just going to lie to you
to maintain their power
as some of us have known from the very
beginning
it's not even that they'll kind of
manipulate the data a little bit to
maintain their power they always do that
that's that's basically the whole point
of statistics it's for politicians and
political activists to manipulate
numbers to control you but this goes way
further than that they'll just lie
they'll just lie with a straight face
right to your face unless we take that
political power back
this is part of the reason why we have
such radical distrust now in our rulers
and our institutions distrust in gensake
in joe biden
obviously distrust in
in dr fauci who says i represent science
then he contradicts himself every five
minutes
we we don't have trust in our
agencies of the federal government
we don't have trust in the elections
themselves okay there is a radical
distrust and that is not our fault
and that's not the fault of conspiracy
theorists and it's not the fault of the
russians and it's not the fault of
conservatives and it's not the fault of
trump it's the fault of the liberal
establishment that squandered all of its
credibility
that's it blame yourselves you wanna
you know who's don't look at me
and say well you you conservatives
you're sowing discord and distrust no
we're not
we're reacting to you people who have
squandered all of that trust the
greatest example yet
51
intelligence agents intelligence
officers members of the deep state
former and present 51 people came out
after the hunter biden laptop story
broke new york post breaks a story we
found hunter biden's laptop it's got a
ton of scandalous material not just
about his sex life not just about his
drug use but about his shady business
dealings in ukraine which is relevant
about his shady business dealings in
china
and even more importantly about his
father's involvement
and potential profiteering from those
shady business deals in ukraine
in china the big guy getting get maybe
getting a little kickback i don't know
we don't know because there was never
permitted to be an investigation because
the liberal establishment i use that
phrase because it includes big tech it
includes the government it includes the
media it's like the whole blob
the liberal establishment shut it down
you couldn't post about the story you
couldn't privately send that story to
other people in direct messages
they rigged the election they rigged the
election damaging information about joe
biden was not allowed to be seen in our
supposedly free marketplace of ideas
with all of our wonderful free speech
and free press protections we don't have
it that doesn't exist we're really good
at criticizing other authoritarian
illiberal governments for for
suppressing freedom of the press we
don't have freedom of the press in
america when push comes to shove
when it actually mattered when the press
broke a story that was really
significant to our presidential election
this whole point of the freedom of the
press is to defend our political order
when that happened the liberal
establishment clamped down and killed it
there is no freedom of the press in
america lock that away with the tooth
fairy and the easter bunny it's not real
and maybe temper your criticism of other
regimes when they also suppress
their freedom of the press because in
america we're really not much better now
we don't kill journalists yet that's
good i'm glad that we don't kill
journalists there are a lot of other
regimes all around the world that do
that
but
we do not permit
relevant information to get into the
public sphere and part of the reason
that we're able to suppress the freedom
of the press here is because intel
intelligence officers come out and they
say well that news report is it's fake
news it's misinformation it's russian
disinformation how many times did you
hear that not just from the intel
officers but from joe biden from the
media from everybody to take a little
trip down memory lane
there are 50 former national
intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian plant you mean the
laptop is now another russia russia
russia hoax the vast majority of the
intelligence people have come out and
said there's no basis at all the
allegations against joe and hunter biden
have no basis in fact who do you think
is behind this
well the russians would be my number one
guest obviously russia would be the
chief suspect this information rudy
giuliani is peddling uh very well could
be connected to some sort of russian
government disinformation campaign so
they're all they speak
with one line they get their talking
points and they say it's all russian
disinformation that's why
frankly even if it were russian
disinformation why can't you debate it
why can't you shoot it down with
evidence well they couldn't shoot it
down with evidence because
as the new york times admitted last week
the hunter biden laptop was real it
wasn't russian disinformation it was
just information
and it was relevant and there was a poll
conducted after the election 12 percent
of biden voters said they wouldn't have
voted for him
had they known that that laptop was real
so it was really significant information
and who signed this let 51 intel
officers signed this letter
about this russian disinformation
jim clapper former director of national
intelligence wow former director of the
defense intelligence agency mike hayden
former director of the cia former
director of the nsa national security
agency leon panetta former director of
the cia former secretary of defense john
brennan he's a he's a
wonderful guy isn't he he's the one who
voted for that communist in american
presidential election also former
director of the cia
former homeland security
counterterrorism adviser at the white
house
lots of list goes on and on and on and
on and it was all
a lie
it was all fake
so this points to a problem not just
with the media
or supposedly free press not just with
big tech
it's with the deep state
it's with our our administrative
agencies which are not
the administrative agencies we call it
the administrative state or the deep
state rights all those little alphabet
agencies that work out of the executive
branch to which congress delegated its
authority to make laws a while ago it's
not like that's just some weird little
ancillary aspect of our government some
little polyp on the body politic that is
our government the administrative
agencies are where
the vast majority of laws that actually
affect our lives are made it's not like
the bill up on capitol hill like school
has rock our government our political
order the political power lives there
and if that area is corrupt
then our government is corrupt and we do
not have
trust in it
adding on to this problem of distrust in
our institutions
is now that we can't believe our own
eyes
this this was the part that really
complicates the transgenderism and
william thomas winning the the women's
swim meet in the ncaa
is
we tell people okay look who are you
going to believe
the ideology of the day or your own
lying eyes the ideology says that will
thomas is a chick but you have your own
eyes and you see that he's obviously a
dude and so
people at le at least for now recognize
okay this guy's a dude
that might not be true
for very long because we're living in an
increasingly digital age
where
national politics is set by viral videos
where national politics is set by
images flickering on our screens where
increasingly we're living in virtual
reality we talk about how we're going to
be living in the metaverse pretty soon
facebook came out and said you're going
to conduct your meetings you're going to
have parties in virtual space you're
going to go into your bedroom and put on
these virtual reality goggles and that's
where you're going to socialize
it's it's it's the world for people who
don't want to live in the world that god
gave them they want to live in the world
that mark zuckerberg created which
sounds hellish to me but it's so
dystopian that it means we're almost
certainly going to live there well if
you're living in that world
it's a lot easier to be manipulated
because people can throw up images in
front of you and you don't know what to
believe i'll give you a perfect example
of this over the weekend there's a
breaking news story
russia is calling for peace in ukraine
now this is great news right wow
russia is gonna they invaded the country
so it's kind of up to russia if the war
is over and
putin came out and he said there's going
to be peace wow what great news except i
didn't believe it when i saw it i don't
really believe any news coming out of
ukraine whether it's on the ukrainian
side or whether it's on the russian side
we are in the fog of war there is an
insane amount of propaganda coming out
of that conflict russia
infamously is one of the greatest
polities for propaganda in the history
of the world i mean the soviets
perfected the art of propaganda and the
west we in the west are not so bad at it
either so i said i just don't believe it
but take a listen if you're watching
right now take a look at this video of
putin declaring peace
i don't speak russian but i can read the
transcript and the transcript says we've
managed to reach peace with ukraine
and he announces the restoration of the
independence of crimea as a republic
within ukraine so he's not not only in
this clip is he saying ukraine gets to
remain a country are you saying actually
crimea which we took eight years ago now
we're going to give that back as a
independent republic within ukraine wow
i know this isn't true i know this would
never happen in a million years but i'm
seeing it happen with my very eyes well
you know what this is i think i've kind
of
hinted at it enough it's a deep fake
but it's a really deep fake
so it sounds like him
it looks like him
the audio syncs up with the mouth
movements
i actually can't believe my lying eyes
forget about we talked about
the all the kind of propaganda coming
out of the war on the ukrainian side we
hear about the ghost of kiev and they've
got video of the airplane this ace
fighter jet shooting down the russians
and it was from a video game it wasn't
real and you're seeing a lot of this
from the russian side too you're seeing
lots of claims being made
about
one of the claims was
from the true fact that ukraine has bio
labs that are funded by the us and run
in collaboration with the us they said
that they had developed an ethnically
targeted bio weapon you know a bio
weapon that just zeros i guess it just
zeros in on the russians but not other
people that seemed a little far-fetched
you're seeing a lot of this propaganda
come out
but now you got this even a video of
putin you can't even believe
that
there's a real breakdown of trust here
and it's why i've got to get to a much
more important story forget about the
complete social breakdown of the
difference between men and women
for a moment forget about the biomedical
tyranny that we've been living under for
two years that totally upended our
society and shut down our economy forget
even about the war in ukraine that could
launch world war three a nuclear power
threatening to use nuclear weapons in
this war in europe
i got to talk about something
potentially more important
kim and kanye and skeet you know the kim
yay
breakup i am unreasonably
fascinated with the kimye breakup and
now kim kardashian is dating this guy
who looks like a meth head who's on on
snl and that would be pete davidson whom
kanye west kim's husband refers to as
skeet so skeet it turns out
is very serious about kim he's gotten
tattoos
about kim kardashian and as she just
told ellen degeneres on her tv show
skeet has branded kim's name into his
skin
there's a tattoo that says kim
um yeah he has a few tattoos a few cute
ones you know that he got um but this
one is a it's not that one the kim one
isn't a tattoo it's actually a branding
like a
branding
because let me explain it because he
wanted to do something that was really
different because like okay first tattoo
we got i was like oh so cute thank you
oh my god you know second whatever i'm
like oh that's so cute but like that's
what tattoo people do right like they
get tattoos of what's going on in their
life and
wait because like that's
special you said first tattoo so he has
three tattoos of you when you say
branding so like literally like an iron
thing yes went on to his body yes to
brand kim yes uh-huh
well you you are a brand i just think he
was like i want something that's there
that i can't you know get rid of my
tattoos because he's in the process of
getting rid of his arm tats
and his neck hats so he's like i don't
want to be able to get rid of it or to
cover it up and i just wanted it like
there as like a scar
on me
but kanye's the crazy one
kanye's cr you see pete davidson gets
multiple tattoos of this married woman
that he's dating and including branding
her name into his skin
but he is normal he's liberal he's on
snl he's friends with all the cool
people he's got he likes hillary clinton
he's totally normal but kanye says hey i
don't want my daughter on tick-tock
kanye
wants to go to church and likes donald
trump so he's the crazy one he's totally
crazy and i j it just made me think
about this crazy label you know you put
the label crazy on somebody and it's
not quite as strong as the word racist
to totally
ostracize somebody but it's pretty close
someone's crazy you're not going to want
to work with that person you don't
associate oh he's just crazy you can
totally dismiss that person
kanye west has had questionable behavior
there's no question about that
but
he is way less crazy than kim
and skeet and the entire liberal
establishment the reason they're going
after kanye is because he's converted to
christianity apparently and makes it a
big part of his life and he voted for
donald trump and he likes to i don't
even remember if he did vote for donald
trump because then he was going to maybe
run for president but he put the maga
hat on
he said basic things like i don't want
my kid on social media
the relatively sort of kind of slightly
traditional values that's enough for
them to call this guy crazy they weren't
calling him crazy when he was doing
insane eccentric leftist behavior they
didn't care that much he was fine but
now that he's voting for trump and
reading the bible now he's a total nut
and if you brand your married
girlfriend's name on your chest you're
oh you're just kind of quirky but you're
not crazy at all
the ruling class is way
crazier than we are okay we i'm not
saying that we who are conservative or
just not leftists i'm not saying we're
without our flaws and foibles but
for all of our flaws and foibles
it is not us it is the ruling class that
says
that men
are secretly women it's the ruling class
that tells the rest of society to go eat
lentils and to go buy a tesla if you're
worried about inflation it's the ruling
class that shuts down our energy
production so we can buy it from iran
and venezuela they are the crazy ones
okay it's the ruling class that shut
down society for two years over a cough
they
are the crazy ones hold on to your
sanity hold on to that grasp of reality
do not let them lead you into delusion
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show